We destroyed Thanos
but it's not over.
My work is inevitable.
There will always be more
to finish it
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
I had a chance to see the Marvels recently,
so this will be my review of the movie.
There's a bunch of stuff
to talk about. A bunch of stuff In the movie.
They used to set up Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty,
so I'll be doing a Post-Credits scene video later.
Full Breakdown.
Easter Eggs after it actually comes out in theaters.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
We also have the Loki Season
two finale coming out around the same time.
I'll be doing a totally separate video for that.
And even though you can totally watch both of them
without having to watch the other
to understand them
both, a lot of what the Marvel's movie is doing.
For example, the Loki finale will help
clarify the direction that things are headed.
So they are meant to be complimentary.
But generally.
Marvel's trying to move away from you. Absolutely.
Having to watch every single thing to understand
every single new thing to
they even just unveiled
like a whole spotlight banner for stuff that's like
totally new, that you don't have to have watched
anything else to have watched
that's meant to be for the upcoming Eggos
series, though.
So that's a completely separate thing
from the Marvel's movie or the Loki series.
so for a lot of you asking the other big question,
do you have to have read the comics or seen the Ms.
Marvel series or the one Division series
to understand the Marvel's movie?
because both of those kind of set up
what's going on with most of the characters
when the movie picks up For the most part,
the answer is no.
As long as you've seen the first Captain Marvel movie,
the Marvel movie does a pretty decent job
of catching up all the non Disney
plus viewers quickly at the beginning of the movie.
so you know who Kamala Khan Ms.
Marvel is Who her family is.
You learn who Monica Rambeau is.
you don't have to have watch Secret Invasion
to know what's going on with Nick Fury
and his saber space station During the movie,
The movie kind of catches you up really quickly.
But for instance, a lot of what happened
at the end of Secret invasion was meant to set up
what's happening in the Marvel's movie in obviously
the Wandavision Post-Credits scene with Monica Rambeau
and then everything during the Ms. Marvel series.
Like literally the end of the Ms.
Marvel series is meant to happen
during the events of the Marvel's movie.
I think they even actually released this full clip
online of what happens right after this moment.
so if you go into the movie, having seen
all this stuff, you are rewarded just like a little bit
more like you do kind of understand
the character dynamics a little bit faster,
the movie is meant to be the next Marvel Phase
five space
based movie after Guardians of the Galaxy
three, explaining how the larger Incursions
storyline begins to affect the main universe
the 616 Earth in the larger Multiverse storyline.
As we head into Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty,
the Council of Kangs gets ready to fight
the new Avengers roster.
Generally in the same way that,
like all new Marvel movies,
have some way of pushing towards
like the next big Avengers movie.
even though Guardians of the Galaxy three
was relatively self-contained to just Guardians stuff,
there were a couple of moments during the movie
setting up larger events that are happening.
the interesting connection, too, is that near the cast
of the director of the movie actually said that
she originally pitched a version of the Marvel movie
that involved time travel and Adam Warlock.
But this was long before Guardians of the Galaxy
three came out and she knew
what was going on in that movie in before she knew
what was going on in the Loki series.
basically she said exactly what you think.
Kevin Feige said, like, No, no, no,
we're already doing time travel on the Loki series.
We're already doing Adam Warlock
and Guardians of the Galaxy three yet
to find some different plot they haven't fully revealed
what that version of the movie is going to look like.
So if we do, I will put it in my full breakdown.
An Easter Eggs video
like my deleted scenes video after the movie comes out.
we already know about a couple
of really big deleted scenes.
but a lot of this movie
explains how the characters deal with what's heading up
towards Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
particularly the Captain Marvel character
with the help of her friends, Monica Rambeau,
who's kind of like her surrogate niece,
even though the way that they age in
the MCU is a little bit differently.
She's aged like a normal person,
so it's like two adults, even though
technically she was a little kid in the last
Captain Marvel movie.
Captain Marvel's powers have basically slowed her
aging down so she doesn't look like she's aged today.
And the addition of Ms.
Marvel, who's like Captain Marvel's new friend,
she's meeting her for the first time
during the events in this movie.
but for Kamala Khan she's been an Avengers fangirl
since the Battle of New York in the first Avengers
movie, and even more so during Avengers Endgame
when the final battle was made public.
Like the knowledge of what actually happened there.
And she became a huge fangirl of Captain
Marvel herself,
that's basically just meant to be an adaptation of her
from the comics.
They've changed a couple of things
and now they've actually recently changed the comics
to make her a little bit
more like the MCU version of Kamala Khan.
Most of the time it's the comics influencing
everything that happens in these comic book movies.
But every once in a while,
the movies influence what happens in the comics,
mostly specific to all the X-Men changes
that they made recently to her character.
Like she is a mutant in the MCU.
Kind of like Namor obviously a big part of the movie
is then tying in the larger
ongoing story elements with Nick Fury's
Saber Space Station,
what he's been doing since the events of Spider-Man,
No Way Home in that Post-Credits scene
that's meant to be an adaptation
of the sword space station from the comics.
But they've also made some changes to that because of
the way they use Sword during the One Division series.
interestingly enough, it's meant to be
one of the shortest movies that Marvel has ever done.
The director, Nia DaCosta, said
that it was always supposed to be super short,
like they went into the movie
planning for it to be super short.
It's only about an hour and 45 minutes long.
If you consider that to be super short, looking at
most of the Marvel movies, that is pretty short.
Like Guardians of the Galaxy
three was more like two and a half hours long.
And Quantum mania was a little over 2 hours.
For the most part,
the Marvel's movie is meant to feel like a super
breezy, quick, kind of wacky adventure at times,
with the three friends
coming together to save the universe and the earth
any of the way had a couple of issues with the movie.
Like there were a few things I didn't think quite were.
Generally
the character work between the three mains was solid.
Iman Vellani is Kamala Khan Ms.
Marvel probably going to be the MVP of the movie?
I think most people will agree
that she's probably going
to be one of the best things to come out of this movie.
she had a lot of the same energy of Spider-Man
during Avengers Infinity War, during the movie,
like the jokes that Spider-Man told In
No Way Home, where he was talking to the others about
fighting aliens in space like it was a fun adventure
he was happy to have had, even though he legit died
during that movie, Like the whole idea
is that during Infinity War he almost dies
several times, then actually did die for a hot minute.
Generally through the movie, though,
he seemed like he was having the time of his life,
just happy to be on the team becoming an avenger,
so to speak.
it's kind of the same vibe with Ms. Marvel.
Like when they did the Ms.
Marvel series, they kind of designed her
to be their new version of Spider-Man, so to speak.
Like the character who was in high school,
who was a fanboy or fangirl
of all this big Avengers level stuff
that was happening around them.
so for her,
this movie is meant to be a big wish fulfillment story,
like getting to meet one of your heroes
and help save the universe.
it'd be like you getting to live your Tumblr dream
that you wrote about a couple of years ago.
But then it actually comes true When I said
some of the movie does get kind of wacky, silly.
I think some people will have issues with that.
Like if you're not a big fan of the sillier
Marvel movies, there are a lot of moments like that
during this.
in generally,
if you did not like the first Captain Marvel movie,
this is better than the first Captain Marvel movie,
but it's still a lot of that same energy.
So like,
this movie is and can completely turn you around
if you're not a big fan of the Captain
Marvel character.
some of the drama between Monica Rambeau
and Captain Marvel at the beginning of the movie
didn't quite work for me as much, but that picked up
during the third act in the big final battle.
After they work through all their differences,
there was a lot of wandavision that they use
to explain this drama
that was going on between the two characters.
So if you watch that series,
there's like a little bit of context for that,
but it felt like it kind of dragged on the movie,
especially at the beginning.
generally the strongest parts of the movie
are the first act
in the third act, which is actually a big surprise
for comic book movies in general.
generally the point where a lot of these big movies
tend to fall apart is the third act
like they have a strong story, but then they don't know
quite how to land the bird, so to speak.
but in the Marvel's movie is actually the second act
is probably the slowest of the film like it drags on.
They have to have some creative ways
to unstick the plot
and just move things into the third act
so the action can pick back up again.
and speaking of the action, it's all pretty solid.
All the fight scenes are great.
Near the cost of the director said that
when she was pitching for the movie,
she actually used a lot of Final Fantasy
Advent children for the fight scenes, the character
moments In general, I think that it paid off
like she generally had the right idea.
one of the other weakest parts of the movie,
though, is the actual overall
main plot with Dar Ben, the Kree, her main
villain plot.
Generally, I think the main villain of the movie
suffers from a lot of the Under-Cooked Marvel
phase one or Marvel Phase three main villain problems
that Marvel used to have.
she just never quite
gets to the level of say like high evolutionary
got during Guardians of the Galaxy three.
Like he's probably one of the best Marvel villains
that they've done next to someone like Loki
Speaking of Loki, to like talking about
really good Marvel villains, although Loki's kind of
turned into more of a hero recently, Zoe Ashton,
who plays Da Ben, the main villain of the movie,
actually has a real life connection with Loki,
like she's the partner of Tom Hiddleston in real life.
They literally just had a baby,
so they're kind of like a full Marvel family now,
in the same way, Like Ewan McGregor
just had a baby with Mary Elizabeth Winstead
in real life,
making them a Star Wars family Overall, as always,
Ashton had a pretty solid performance of the material
she was given.
It's just that
her storyline in particular was not that strong
compared to, say, like high evolutionary story.
maybe that would have benefitted
from like a slightly longer movie.
Usually when movies are shorter,
that's what tends to suffer most of the talk.
This weekend after the movie comes out
everywhere will be on the end of the movie,
like the big final battle in the post-credits scene.
So no spoilers in this video.
If you do get a chance to see the movie early,
please don't post spoilers in the comments.
I will do a much longer Post-Credits
scene video on Friday.
Like a full breakdown
of all the Easter eggs in the movie on Saturday.
We will talk about all that stuff
and there is a lot, a lot to talk about.
They're finally doing some of the things
that everybody's been waiting for them to do.
overall, the final act,
like the big final battle, is some solid Marvel action.
There were a few CG shots
that were a little raw, but but nothing like the issues
that Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantumania had in generally ranking the Marvel movies
so far this year, I would say Guardians of the Galaxy
three Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse are still peak
like some of the best Marvel movies ever,
not just this year.
But they are like the two best big comic
book movies this year by a very wide margin.
The Marvel's movie is better than quantum mania,
but it's nowhere near
as good as, say, like Guardians or Spider-Verse.
And it was better like I said, than the first Captain
Marvel movie.
you can definitely tell behind the scenes.
Marvel is trying to address
a lot of the complaints against it this past year,
but because the majority of the movie was filmed
and edited before the complaints really started
to come down against them,
there's only so much of that that they can address
in post-production and reshoots once the movie is done.
The music score was great. The original score.
This is also a banner year
for Beastie Boys in Marvel movies.
Generally, the direction for Nia D'Costa was solid.
She's also a noted X-Men
comic book stance, and she was a little kid.
She even said that she pitched a Cyclops
in a storm team movie before Marvel
hired her to direct this movie.
since I know everybody has been talking about X-Men
the past few months in
so much of the trailers were hyping up
X-Men related stuff.
like I said, no spoilers in this video,
but do stay through the credits
for the Mid-Credits scene in the post credits scenes.
Next to the Loki finale.
It is probably going to be
the most talked about thing this weekend.
there is one mid-credits scene
in sort of like a funny post-credits scene.
The one everybody's going to be talking about
is technically the mid-credits
scene that's meant to be very heavily plot related.
the actual post-credits scene is more of like a funny
moment referencing things from earlier in the movie.
It isn't really plot related.
my full videos for both of those will post
after my Loki finale video on Friday,
so be sure to go see the movie as soon as you can
Everyone click here for my Post-Credits scene video.
Update the link as soon as I post that and click here
for my Loki finale video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!